ils sont gonflables depuis leur victoire
à la Cour suprême car rejeté la
jurisprudence Row controwade et qui a
donné le droit à chaque État d'interdire
ou de restreindre le droit à
l'avortement
nous sommes la génération poste
pour beaucoup ici la vie du fœtus
commence dès la conception
tout le monde a droit à la vie dit-elle
et on ne devrait pas enlever ce droit à
quelqu'un qui n'a pas de voix
chaque être humain une valeur dit-il de
la conception jusqu'à la mort
[Musique]
naturellement de défendre les vraies
valeurs de la famille traditionnelle et
être en faveur de la vie le mot choix ou
droit de la femme de disposer de son
corps ne font pas partie du discours
j'ai perdu deux bébés dit-elle pour ces
quelques semaines ils étaient vivants en
moi
et ça me bouleverse de voir que la seule
option de certaines femmes et la mort de
leur enfant
j'ai survécu un avortement dit celle-ci
ils ont essayé de m'aspirer dans une
clinique
et j'en suis sorti vivante après leur
victoire à la Cour suprême les
manifestants entiers avortement en
profit se dirige maintenant vers le
Capitole ils vise le Congrès pour que le
droit l'avortement soit interdit aux
pays une fois pour toute
et il compte mener leur bataille étape
par étape
s ont voté à 55% pour inscrire la
liberté reproductive dans leur
constitutions
elle ne fait que commencer dans les 50
états du pays
en plus du Michigan le Vermont et la
Californie ont inscrit le droit à
l'avortement dans leur constitution même
le très conservateur kentaky a refusé
d'interdire le droit à l'avortement dans
sa constitution
nous avons tué 63 millions d'enfants
dit-il depuis l'arrêt en 1973
il faut que le Congrès criminalise une
fois pour toute l'avortement
dimanche la vice-présidente livrera un
discours en Floride pour marquer
l'anniversaire du droit à l'avortement
en 1973 depuis la jurisprudence
recontrewade
mais 50 ans plus tard le pays est
toujours aussi divisé sur la question
et si elles aboient Radio-Canada
Washington
[Musique]